die deutsche Hauptstadt braucht dringend
einen neuen Wasserspender
ansonsten wird dramatische Auswirkungen
haben hinsichtlich der Gewinnung von
Trinkwasser schon bald werden Milliarden
Kubikmeter Wasser benötigt um die
riesigen Braunkohle Löcher zu füllen die
der Tagebau hinterlassen hat
[Musik]
hier wird man neue Wasserquellen
abschließen müssen der Plan die Elbe
soll angezapft werden um Berlin vor dem
Austrocknen zu bewahren kann das gut
gehen ich sage ganz klar an der Stelle
wir lassen uns von Berlin hier das
Wasser nicht abgraben
niemand will etwas abgeben wenn Wasser
zur Mangelware wird
es ist davon auszugehen dass die gesamte
Situation in den nächsten Jahren noch
deutlich kritischer wird
Wasser im Überfluss das war einmal
[Musik]
das Wasser glasklar und das Ufer schön
flach
der sediner See in Brandenburg ist vor
allem bei Familien sehr beliebt doch das
Badeparadies ist bedroht der See
trocknet aus früher stand das Wasser bis
zu dieser Kante
als Kind haben wir uns hier ein Seil
über die erste geschmissen und haben uns
von hier aus ins Wasser geschwungen ja
und so gesprungen heute wäre das hier
im Genickbruch glatter glaube ich
zumindestens beim Bruch es würde weh tun
ja seitdem ist der Pegel um fast zwei
Meter gesunken der See wird Jahr für
Jahr kleiner
irgendwann haben wir dann keinen See
mehr
aus ja das ist halt blöd wenn der Weg
ist
haben wir auch keine Tiere mehr im
Wasser wieder drin leben könnten z.B
oder so da habe ich ja auch nicht schön
man sieht es hier diese beweisende
Halbinsel hat sich mittlerweile gebildet
das bedeutet der große sedina fällt eben
in Ost und in den westbecken der
verlandet zunehmend
Sommer für Sommer sehen die Anwohner
ihren See nach und nach verschwinden
von Wasser
sondern es ist eben
Freunde es ist zusammenkommen
am See treffen sich nicht nur die
Bewohner des Dorfes bei immer heißeren
Sommer ist der weit darüber hinaus ein
Anziehungspunkt
[Musik]
gespeist wird er sie hauptsächlich über
das Grundwasser und das ist ein Problem
denn der Grundwasserspiegel sinkt
nicht nur am Seddiner See
[Musik]
in ganz Deutschland wird es wärmer wegen
des Klimawandels das bedeutet es
verdunstet auch mehr Wasser vor allem im
Osten hat das folgen die Landschaft
trocknet aus
[Musik]
der Geowissenschaftler Hagen Koch
beobachtet diese Entwicklung am weltweit
renommierten Potsdamer Institut für
Klimafolgenforschung
dort ist das schon immer so dass wir
deutlich geringere Niederschläge haben
als z.B in den westlichen Bundesländern
wir haben aber in der Region teilweise
deutlich höhere Temperaturen das hat
sich jetzt noch einmal verstärkt und die
Temperatur Zunahme ist besonders in dem
Bundesländern Brandenburg und Berlin
also im Zentrum Ostdeutschlands
besonders hoch auch etwas höher als in
den westlichen Bundesländern
die hohen Temperaturen führen vermehrt
zu Starkregen das heißt extrem viel
Wasser auf kleiner Fläche
wenn es dann mal regnet dann sind es
sehr häufig auch stark Niederschläge das
heißt dieses Wasser fließt schnell ab
und dient zum Beispiel nicht dazu das
Grundwasser aufzufüllen
[Musik]
in der Nähe von Berlin treffen wir
Eckart Scheffler er beobachtet seit fast
einem halben Jahrhundert wie alles immer
trockener wird
[Musik]
er zeigt uns ein Bächlein dass seit
Jahren im Sommer austrocknet doch heute
eine Überraschung
und die Freude die hier für so ein
Dorfbewohner überspringt ist das hier
wieder Wasser drin ist durch diese
massiven Niederschläge der letzten Tage
hat das Vlies wieder Wasser das fließt
das ist dieser Bach oder das was davon
übrig ist zwischen dem Schild ist ein
bisschen Wasser mit bloßem Auge kaum zu
erkennen
in den 90er Jahren hatten wir hier noch
Wasser drinne da haben wir im Sommer
nach der Ernte drin gebadet es war
wunderschön das kühlte ab und diese
diese stachelein das heißt die hat man
da alles abgespielt seit den 90er Jahren
also nicht mehr möglich
im Auftrag des Brandenburger Umweltamtes
seit Jahrzehnten regelmäßig den Pegel
des Grundwassers vor Ort
und der singt beständig
bei fünf Meter neuen das heißt das Tempo
wie singt dem Zug genau die
Beschleunigung ist sind das Sinken es
hat zugenommen
Eckart Scheffler folgt dem Bachlauf
Richtung Berlin derselbe Bach in dem er
früher gebadet hat
ja
[Musik]
hier hat eine Grundwasserabsenkung
gegeben von sechs bis acht Metern die zu
dieser Austrocknung führte das geht
schon seit Jahrzehnten sieht ja fast aus
wie eine Wanderweg Wanderweg ist es auch
für die wildschweinchen ich nenne das
immer wildschweinautobahnen die gehen
hier sehr gerne lang
[Musik]
in der Bach verläuft durch einen
Naturschutzgebiet das vertrocknet jetzt
die Bäume sterben ab
ein paar Meter weiter einer der Brunnen
die Berlin mit Wasser versorgen hier
wird schon seit Jahren mehr entnommen
als ein frischem Wasser nachkommt
nachhaltig ist das nicht
ja leben wir vom Ersparten und diese
nachhaltige Lösung die ist nicht in
Sicht wir leben ja auf Kredit für unsere
von unseren Kindern und Kindeskindern
die Suche nach dem Wasser für Berlin
gestaltet sich schwierig
also überall längere Zeit wurde auch
diskutiert ob aus dem Umland Wasser nach
Berlin sozusagen von den Wasserwerken in
Brandenburg geliefert werden konnten
davon ist man mittlerweile ab gekommen
weil der Wasserbedarf im sogenannten
Speckgürtel so gestiegen ist dass die
Wasserwerke dort auch einer
Kapazitätsgrenze arbeiten und Berlin
kein Wasser zur Verfügung stellen können
Berlin keine andere deutsche Stadt
braucht so viel Wasser bislang ist die
Versorgung gesichert auch dank der Spray
die mitten durch die Hauptstadt fließt
die Spree ist eine der wichtigen
Wasserquellen der Millionen Metropole
das Trinkwasser für die Stadt stammt vor
allem aus dem Südosten Berlins hier
fließt die Spree durch den Müggelsee
rund um den See befinden sich über 100
Brunnen
diese Brunnen ziehen das Wasser aus dem
See als sogenanntes ufer-
außerdem nutzen die Brunnen Grundwasser
das von einer benachbarten Hochfläche
herabfließt
innerhalb der letzten 100 Jahre hat sich
der Grundwasserspiegel an den Brunnen
abgesenkt um bis zu 6 Metern
damit nicht genug von der benachbarten
Hochfläche kommt immer weniger
Grundwasser weil es immer weniger regnet
und heißer wird
die Folge das Trinkwasser für Berlin
kommt mittlerweile zu einem Großteil aus
dem Müggelsee
und der Müggelsee bekommt das Wasser aus
der Spree
das bedeutet wenn die Spree zu wenig
Wasser führt reicht es nicht mehr für
die Versorgung der Bundeshauptstadt
noch hat die Spree ausreichend Wasser
doch das könnte sich bald ändern
wir sind rund 300 km flussaufwärts
und treffen Christoph Gerst Graser er
ist der Mann fürs Wasser und hat im
Auftrag des Umweltbundesamtes den
passahhaushalt der Spree untersucht
er zeigt uns was den Fluss noch am Leben
hält künstliche Einleitungen hier an
dieser Einleitstelle fließen 700 Liter
Grundwasser pro Sekunde in die Spree
insgesamt haben wir vier einleitstellen
und in Summe kann das sein dass dann im
Sommer wenn es trocken ist dieses
gereinigte eingeleitete Wasser bis zu
75% des spreeabflusses ausmacht
und das heißt dreiviertel des Wassers
das hier in der Spray fließt ist kein
natürliches Flusswasser sondern wird
eingeleitet
es stammt aus dem nahegelegenen
Braunkohletagebau in der Lausitz
damit die Riesen Löcher nicht voll
laufen wird das Grundwasser ständig
abgepumpt und fließt dann wie hier in
die Spray
ausgerechnet der Klimakiller Braunkohle
hält den Fluss mit ständigen
wasserspenden am Leben
Wasser wegfallt müssen wir uns eine
Alternative überlegen ansonsten wird es
dramatische Auswirkungen haben Hinsicht
der Ökologie hinsichtlich der Nutzung
und auch das der Gewinnung von
Trinkwasser vor allem in Berlin
das Trinkwasser in Berlin hängt also von
der braunen Kohle in der Lausitz ab doch
damit ist Schluss nach dem
braunkohleausstieg und der kann bereits
2030 kommen dann werden die Pumpen
abgestellt und es läuft kein
zusätzliches Wasser mehr in die Spree
[Musik]
hinzu kommt das knappe Wasser der Spree
muss dann auch noch die riesigen Löcher
des Tagebaus füllen
die Folge der Fluss könnte dann im
Sommer austrocknen
und das ist nicht nur für Berlin ein
Problem sondern auch für den Spreewald
[Musik]
das einzigartige Ökosystem verfügt über
einen Kanalnetz von rund 1000 km Länge
die Region lebt vom Wasser mit seinen
Touristen die Kähne fahren im Sommer
praktisch auf groben Wasser
was ist wenn das fehlt wenn das fehlt
dann fehlt es dann haben manche einer
haarerlebnis und Wundern sie was ist
jetzt da los weil wir haben uns seit
über zwei Generationen an dieses Wasser
aus dem Tagebau gewöhnt man merkt sie
jetzt schon wenn es im Sommer trocken
ist es sind die Fliese trocken es kommt
zum stinken an wir bekommen hygienische
Probleme und das wird natürlich dann
irgendwann zunehmen das ist logisch
erst Grasart trifft im Spreehafen einen
alten Freund
der ist Hafenmeister in Burg jedes Jahr
gibt es alleine in diesem Ort mehr als
700.000 Übernachtungen ein
Tourismusmagnet im Spreewald
geht ja gar nichts und man sieht ja
bei guten Wetter wird jeder im Kahn das
ist der Schlüsselelement im Spreewald
Tourismus
die Seele würde ich sagen
es dreht sich eigentlich alles um die
Kahnfahrt
wegen des Wassers macht sich der
Hafenmeister keine großen Sorgen
also keine Angst davor dass der
Spreewald trocken fällt im Augenblick
nicht ich habe ja immer befreundet mit
Christoph
wir tun dabei das beide sehr viel dafür
dass es eben nicht so ist das also auch
in 100 Jahren hier noch kein fahren
können
doch dafür braucht die Spree unbedingt
einen neuen Wasserspender
für den Experten gerstgraser ist das
völlig klar
ohne Wasser aus einem anderen
Einzugsgebiet wären gravierende
Auswirkungen des Wasserhaushalts auch in
Berlin zu spüren sein
diese Studie des Umweltbundesamtes hat
untersucht wo das fehlende Wasser
herkommen soll Ergebnis für die Spree
muss ein anderer Fluss angezapft werden
[Musik]
200 km südlich von Berlin gibt es so
einen Fluss
die Elbe
wir sind im Elbsandsteingebirge
die Elbe könnte das nötige Wasser für
die Spray liefern sie hat ein viel
größeres Einzugsgebiet als die Spree und
somit auch viel mehr Wasser
abzugeben findet er eine sehr schlechte
Idee Ivo Teichmann ist
Landtagsabgeordneter in Sachsen und Chef
des örtlichen Tourismusvereins am Ufer
der Elbe ist der aufgewachsen
ja ich habe von Kindheit an hier an der
Elbe ge angelt sehr gern geangelt die
Elbe ist der fischreichste Fluss in
Europa und es hat Spaß gemacht direkt
hier hinterm Geländer am Ufer
hier zur Angeln da war der Wasserstand
noch viel höher jetzt ist das natürlich
alles Geschichte weil sie sehen ja
überall gucken die Steine raus der LP
Pegel ist enorm gesunken im Sommer
niedrige Pegelstände
das ist inzwischen normal und schlecht
für den Tourismus
der Wasserpegel ist so niedrig dass
selbst die Weiße Flotte jetzt schon ihre
gute
ausdünnen musste weil der Wasserpegel zu
gering ist und das ist jetzt öfter im
Sommer der Fall ja regelmäßig weiter
also ich bekomme ja als
tourismusvereinsvorsitzender die
E-Mails von der weißen Platte und die
kommen in also aller paar Tage gekommen
Änderungen weil der Wasserpegel zu wenig
ist die Elbe hat über das Jahr gesehen
immer noch genug Wasser übrig sagen der
hydrogiologe Wilfried Ullmann und sein
Kollege Kai Zimmermann sie haben für die
Studie des Umweltbundesamtes untersucht
wo genau man die Elbe anzapfen kann
es gibt einen kurzen Weg das aber sehr
schwierig da muss man durch dickes
Grundgebirge durch es gibt ein ganz
langweg da muss man dann die elsterhaube
hoch
schließlich hat Ullmann die beste
Ansatzstelle gefunden hier in einem
alten Hafenbecken an der Elbe in der
Sächsischen Schweiz in Possen warum ist
das hier perfekt weil wir hier an einem
Punkt sind wo die Elbe hier so ziemlich
den höchsten Wasserspiegel hat und Ort
wo es günstig ist rein von den
Bedingungen die Elbe hier anzuzapfen
weil wir müssen ja von einer Höhe auf
die andere Höhe in die Spree kommen das
Elbwasser müsste dann aus diesem
Hafenbecken den Elbhang hochgepumpt
werden
was wurde irgendwo an dem Hang passieren
bzw auf dem Platte oder dort oben dort
würde das Wasser dann in einem Tunnel
verschwinden das verschwindet dann
praktische Schachteln genau und hat doch
die Höhe das ist auch frei auslaufen
kann in Richtung der spreche
und so könnte es aussehen
wenn die Elbe viel Wasser hat heben
Pumpen das Wasser aus dem Hafenbecken
durch Rohre und 90 m bergauf
oberhalb von großen strömt es in einen
eigens zu errichtenden Tunnel
der ist rund 30 Kilometer lang
in der Nähe von Bautzen gelangt das
Elbwasser dann in die Spree
der Vorteil dass Abwasser kann
anschließend in der Lausitz gespeichert
werden den Talsperren und den gefluteten
Tagebau sehen
diese sehen nehmen dann das Elbwasser
auf
und geben es an die Spree ab mit der
Fluss zu wenig Wasser führt
unwahrt der Spree fließt noch ein
anderer großer Fluss
die oder
doch zwischen oder und Berlin gibt es
keine Seen um das Wasser zu speichern
anders beim Elbwasser
da ist gespeichert werden kann kann es
im Sommer in die Spree fließen und den
Spreewald und Berlin vom Austrocknen
bewahren das klingt erst einmal nach
einer guten Lösung
wir gleichen aus wir gleichen aus und
nehmen Überschuss an einer Stelle Weg um
Defizit an einer anderen Stelle
auszugleichen gut aber dadurch muss man
sein einer Stelle wegnehmen und da wird
es dann doch wahrscheinlich zu
Konflikten kommen oder was heißt
Konflikte wenn der Fluss genügend Wasser
führt kein Wassermangel hat vor allem
bei kleineren hochmessern oder im
Winterhalbjahr ist das doch
unproblematisch
die Idee also nur wenn die Elbe auch
genügend Wasser hat wird sie angezapft
sonst nicht
Ivo Teichmann will sich auf solche
Zusagen nicht einlassen er war früher
afd-mitglied und ist jetzt Mitglied der
neuen konservativen Partei Bündnis
Deutschland
wie viele Menschen hier misst haut er
der Berliner Politik
wenn einmal so eine Leitung gebaut ist
ist doch zu befürchten dass dann wenn
Wasser Not ist dann doch mehr oder
weniger heimlich oder offiziell wie auch
immer Wasser abgeleitet wird wir
brauchen Löschwasser wir brauchen Wasser
für die Wirtschaft in der Region wir
brauchen Wasser als Trinkwasser in
Dresden also wir haben selber ein riesen
Wasserbedarf und es tut mir leid das
jetzt hier zu entscheiden noch Wasser
wegzugeben in der Situation
ja aber es wird ja gesagt dass sie nur
das Wasser nehmen wenn wirklich genügend
da ist ja da habe ich keinen vertrauen
wir haben auch gesagt vom Jahr wir
liefern keine Panzer und die Ukraine und
liefern jetzt in soweit ist Politik
veränderbar veränderlich je nachdem wer
sagen hat
etwas Wasser abgeben auch die sächsische
Landesregierung in Dresden ist skeptisch
denn nicht nur Berlin auch Sachsen hat
aufgrund des Klimawandels immer weniger
Wasser
[Musik]
und das bereitet auch dem sächsischen
Umweltminister sorgen
[Musik]
gibt es in Zukunft Wasser aus der Elbe
für die Lausitz mein Gefühl sagt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht sehr groß
dass das eine gute Lösung ist aber wir
wollen das Fakten passieren
also erst einmal prüfen doch eines ist
jetzt schon klar der Industriestandort
darf nicht gefährdet werden
allein in Dresden wir sind hier der
größte Mikrochip Fertigungsstandort für
ganz Europa da gibt es erhebliche
Bedarfe auch für weitere
Industrieansiedlung für unsere
Bevölkerung und das alles müssen wir
auch teilweise aus Elbe Wasser
gewährleisten
Wasser wird zum Standortfaktor
in Dresden steht eine große chip-fabrik
von Infineon und diese soll ausgebaut
werden
[Musik]
doch das ist noch nicht alles
abwärts bei Magdeburg entsteht eine noch
viel größere chip-fabrik von Intel
und auch entlang der Spree brauchen neue
Hightech Fabriken Wasser
zum Beispiel Tesla bei Berlin der
Autobauer will sein Werk erweitern und
sucht dafür eine neue Wasserquelle
[Musik]
schon heute ist der Wasserverbrauch hoch
Tesla benötigt 1,4 Millionen Kubikmeter
pro Jahr
was kaum bekannt ist noch viel durstiger
sind die Braunkohlekraftwerke von League
in der Lausitz sie schlucken rund 100
Millionen Kubikmeter im Jahr
die Braunkohlekraftwerke sind die
größten Wasserverbraucher in
Ostdeutschland das meiste Wasser geht
drauf für die Kühltürme
noch sind die braunkohlemeiler
unverzichtbar für die Energiesicherheit
in ganz Deutschland
doch mit der Energiewende sollen sie
ersetzt werden durch
wasserstoffkraftwerke erst im Frühjahr
übergab Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck einen Förderbescheid für das neue
Referenzkraftwerk in der Lausitz
das Problem auch die neuen
klimaschonenden wasserstoffkraftwerke
brauchen Wasser zum Kühlen und es
braucht Wasser für den Wasserstoff
[Musik]
auch die grüne Technologie benötigt noch
47 Millionen Kubikmeter pro Jahr so
Schätzungen des Umweltbundesamtes
im Hinblick auf die Energiewende zum
Beispiel Ersatz durch
wasserstoffkraftwerke wird Wasser
natürlich auch in einer herrlichen Maße
benötigt das heißt Energiewende geht
hier nicht ohne Wasser
Energiewende wenn wir das Andenken dass
wir so wie wir großes Kraftwerk im
Hintergrund sehen so ähnliches großes
Kraftwerk aber er riecht nach
wasserstoffbasis dann brauche ich dafür
natürlich auch eine erhebliche Menge an
Wasser
und dieses Wasser kann nicht mehr wie
bisher aus dem Tagebau kommen der wird
mit dem Kohleausstieg eingestellt
[Musik]
woher dann das viele Kühlwasser kommen
soll das ist noch völlig unklar klar ist
nur die Spree kann das nicht leisten sie
hat nicht genug Wasser sie braucht
wasserhilfe der Elbe auch für die
Energiewende
doch der grüne Umweltminister Sachsens
bleibt skeptisch Energiewende hin oder
her er will lieber eine naturheilung
wir haben seit 2018 allein fünf
ausgeprägte trockenjahre hier im
Freistaat Sachsen erlebt das heißt
Wasser was einmal kommt ist viel zu
kostbar um es Schmerz zu leiten und das
bedeutet Speicherfähigkeit in der
Landschaft mit allen Instrumenten und
schwammverhalten nennt sich das wir
müssen unsere Gewässer renaturieren wir
müssen dort wieder lebendige auch
speicherfähige und finden also ein
breites Bündel von Maßnahmen wird
gebraucht
die Natur soll also das Wasser speichern
in Flussauen
davon gibt es einige entlang der Elbe
diese sollen dazu beitragen das Wasser
Problem zu lösen auch an der Spree
[Musik]
unweit von Cottbus gibt es eine solche
Aue
11 km Spray wurden dafür renaturiert
[Musik]
Renaturierung macht absoluten Sinn aus
hydrologischer Sicht aus ökologischer
Sicht aber
Renaturierung alleine wird unser
wasserwirtschaftliches Problem noch die
Ausstieg aus der Kohle nicht lösen
diese Renaturierung entlang der Spree
hat gerstgraser geplant und umgesetzt
[Musik]
seitdem hat die Artenvielfalt deutlich
zugenommen die vielen Pflanzen
unterstützen die Selbstreinigung des
Wassers der große Vorteil bei Hochwasser
wird die Aue überflutet und schützt so
flussabwärts vor Überschwemmungen
der Nachteil die wilde Natur ist durstig
sie schluckt jede Menge Wasser
[Musik]
es verdunstet und es wird in den Zellen
eingelagert es wächst natürlich hier wie
verrückt das merken wir hier wir sehen
es am Schilf wir sehen es an den Bäumen
in welch kurzer Zeit welche Größen diese
Bäume erreicht haben weil Wasser Licht
der Boden ist natürlich wunderbar
Nachteil ist es kommt natürlich im
Unterlauf dann viel weniger Wasser an
das bedeutet fehlt nach dem
Kohleausstieg das Wasser aus den Tage
bauen dann hilft so eine Aue nicht im
Gegenteil
in wirklich trockenen Phasen kann die
Renaturierung eine Arbeit das
wasserdefizit aus dem Bergbau in
keinster Weise ausgleichen im Gegenteil
es verstärkt es sogar nur weil er der
Auwald im Sommer bei trocknet
unglaubliche Mengen an Wasser selber
verbraucht
Wasser das in Berlin fehlt für
gastgraser ist deshalb klar zur
elbüberleitung gibt es keine Alternative
diese wasserüberleitung ist auch im
Sinne der deutschen wasserstrategie die
wird auch in anderen Einzugsgebieten mit
Sicherheit angewandt werden müssen das
Wasser aus Einzugsgebieten die
temporärwasser haben in Gebiete
übergeleitet wird das temporär weniger
Wasser hat
so muss in Zeiten des Klimawandels
fehlendes Wasser von dort beschafft
werden wo noch genügend Wasser da ist
[Musik]
zurück in Berlin der Landesregierung ist
mittlerweile klar die Millionenstadt
bekommt ein handfestes Wasserproblem was
also ist der Plan
zur offensichtlich notwendigen Elb
Überleitung kein Interview schriftlich
erklärt der Berliner Senat in bestem
Bürokraten deutsch
[Musik]
die Prüfung der Umsetzbarkeit ist
bereits Gegenstand laufender
Untersuchungen
der Senat prüft also erstmal ohne Elb
Überleitung braucht es einen Plan B
Hagen Koch schlägt vor gebrauchtes
Wasser wiederverwenden das wäre in
Berlin extrem aufwendig
hier wäre die einzige Möglichkeit wir
müssten das gesamte
Wasserversorgungsnetz in Berlin umbauen
in zwei separate Netze ein Netz was für
Trinkwasser genutzt wird und ein zweites
grauwassernetz wo dann zum Beispiel das
Wasser was sozusagen nach dem Abwaschen
bisher verloren geht aufgefangen wird um
es dann für die Toilettenspülung oder
nach einer
Vorreinigung für die Waschmaschine zu
nutzen das heißt wir bräuchten
Milliarden Investitionen in Berlin um
das jetzige Netz in zwei parallel Netze
umzubauen
der unwahrscheinlich dass Berlin so viel
Geld hat noch unwahrscheinlicher ist das
Berlin es schaffen könnte in
Hunderttausenden Gebäuden das
Abwassersystem grundlegend umzubauen
und so bleibt der Hauptstadt nur die
Hoffnung auf das Wasser der Elbe und
darauf dass die Anwohner hier ein
Einsehen haben und etwas von ihrem
Wasser ab
ich habe in meinem Wahlkreis hier mein
Wahlkreis City Sächsische Schweiz mit
Bürgern darüber gesprochen und durchweg
eine Meinung
nein wir wollen das nicht die sind wohl
verrückt große Befürchtung ist natürlich
auch in Berlin wird das Wasser gebraucht
in Berlin wird die Entscheidung fallen
und
ich sage ganz klar an der Stelle wir
lassen uns von Berlin hier das Wasser
nicht abgraben
entscheiden werden die Bundesländer wer
wie viel Wasser abgibt und bekommt
lange Zeit war in Deutschland Wasser im
Überfluss da für Haushalte und Industrie
das ändert sich jetzt und der Kampf ums
Wasser beginnt